[Music]
hi guys it's Quinn here if you
appreciate my content consider hitting
the like buttons the only way the
YouTube algorithm notices me if you'd
like to do more to keep the channel to
float consider donating through the
PayPal Link in the description or
checking out our patreon thanks guys so
much luan's remembrance of Earth's past
Trilogy is one of the most compelling
modern Sci-Fi series in my opinion if
you like science fiction that really
zooms out and drives its speculative
ideas out literally to the end of time
then this is probably the series for you
now I of course have several videos
covering several aspects of this series
but in this video we will get to a topic
that has been requested for a very long
time and that is the wall facers and the
wall
breakers now obviously if you have not
read the series this video is going to
be full of spoilers although most of it
would probably go over your head anyway
but if you have read the books or at
least seen my previous videos or you
just don't care about spoilers then feel
free to continue forward
part one the wallf facer
project the series of course follows
Humanity as we deal with the knowledge
that a powerful race of alien beings has
set its sights on Earth and will arrive
within 400 years these beings called the
tricin are from a star system
approximately four light years away they
inhabit a planet within an unstable
three star system but they desire Earth
they launch a kind of probe at Earth
called a sofon it is is essentially a
Quantum supercomputer that could not
only transmit data from Earth to tric
Solaris in real time but could also
affect Earth in physical ways the trican
mainly use the sofon to limit human
scientific development rendering physics
useless they don't want Humanity
developing to a competitive level in the
400 years that it would take them to
reach Earth they also use the soons to
communicate with triolian allies on
Earth the members of etto the Earth tric
Solaris organization or as I like to
call them the traders of
humanity now this is where it gets
interesting the Sans also have
limitations the main one being that
though they can see everything that is
happening on Earth they cannot read
human thoughts and Humanity eventually
figures this out this is where the Wall
facers come in the wall faer project was
enacted in year three of the crisis era
the idea behind the wall wall faer
project was as follows four humans would
be chosen by the United Nations
planetary defense Council each of the
four wall facers would be given near
unlimited power have access to unlimited
funds have the ability to act without
question and make request that would be
followed no matter how absurd while
facing minimal scrutiny their main
limitation was that they could never
share their plans with others for then
the trican would know
the wallf facer project was established
and four men were ultimately chosen
Frederick Tyler a former United States
Secretary of Defense Bill Hines a
British
neuroscientist Manuel Ray Diaz who had
once been the president of Venezuela and
of course Lu G just an ordinary
astronomer by far the least qualified of
the four the wall faers would be
expected to misdirect the trican
obscuring their true aims
they would use cryic technology in order
to hibernate for long periods of time
over the course of the Journey of the
trican fleet to Earth each of the wall
facers developed a unique plan and in
the end all but one failed at the time
all of this was being worked out of
course the trican were watching and
developing a counter to the wall faer
project or at least ETO was the wall
breaker project they would choose from
the ranks of etto a wall breaker to
counter each wall facer deciphering
their plans and exposing them to tric
Solaris the exact identities of the wall
breakers remain at first unknown but are
revealed at later times in the series
The tricin were intelligent and advanced
but due to the nature in which they had
evolved to communicate they lacked the
ability to lie they did not understand
deception this is why etto and the wall
breakers were necessary we will appoint
a wall breaker for each wall facer like
the wall facers the wall breakers will
be authorized to tap all of the
organizations for resources but their
greatest resource will be the soof funds
which will render the wall facers every
action utterly exposed the only secret
will be their thoughts the wall
breaker's Mission then is to analyze the
wall facers open and clandestine actions
with the help of the sof funds and
decipher the true nature of their
strategic aims as early as possible the
leadership will now appoint the wall
breakers four wall breakers were
appointed one for each wall facer as I
said each wall facer was required to
develop a unique plan we'll start with
Frederick
Tyler part two Frederick Tyler's
plan as I said Frederick Tyler was a
former US Secretary of Defense he also
authored a book titled the truth of tech
technology apparently in this book he
argued that small countries could reap
significant benefits from technology and
were in fact the ultimate beneficiaries
of Technology suggesting that
technological Pursuits of larger nations
would in the end shift the global Power
Balance in favor of smaller ones
publicly Tyler proposed to plan to
create a swarm of kamakazi fto crafts to
confront the trican fleet however
privately his true intentions which
would UL be unveiled by his wall breaker
would prove to be traitorous initially
Tyler may have worked to help Humanity
But as time went on he developed a
resentment for Humanity which only
continued to grow simultaneously his
appreciation for the tricar and the
members of etto also grew he traveled
the world becoming disillusioned with
modern Humanity he was convinced that
Humanity did not stand a chance at
defeating tric Solaris in standard
combat of course this was only the
beginning your betrayal of humanity
would be a long process but you had time
on your side in the following months and
years you were prepared to engineer
events that would add to the wall you
erected between yourself and the human
race your despair would gradually grow
and your sorrow intensify and you would
leave the human world further and
further behind growing closer and closer
to EO and tric Solaris Tyler had
actually planned to use the swarm of
kamakazi Fighters to ATT attack
Humanity's own Fleet he had intended to
enlist members of etto to Pilot the
crafts he had also planned to transport
water to the approaching trican Fleet
recognizing their potential need for it
after their long space journey the etto
mosquito Fleet would launch a sneak
attack on the space force and then flee
to the trican who might be willing to
let them join their Fleet once they had
demonstrated their disloyalty to
humanity Tyler is eventually confronted
by his wall breaker who has discovered
Tyler's plan and would expose him in a
frail voice the pitiful man uttered his
first sentence it struck Tyler like a
bolt of lightning and so dazed him that
he practically sat down on the ground
every word was like a
Thunderclap wall fa sir Frederick Tyler
I am your wall
breaker okay so now a warning this is
where it gets pretty dark confronted
with the futility of his plan and unable
to resign from his wall faer Ro
Frederick Tyler chooses to take his own
life after disclosing his scheme to Lu G
and there you have it history would mark
this as the first major failure in the
already questionable wallf facer
project part three Bill hines's
plan in the dark Forest wallfacer Bill
Hines a British neuroscientist
experiments with a piece of tech known
as a resolving imager and makes a
discovery he finds that if a subject
under goes an enhanced radiation scan
immediately after affirming a false
statement they will subsequently regard
that statement as true essentially
forming a mental
seal I won't talk about the details
basically we discovered the mind's
mechanism for making judgments in the
cerebral neural network as well as the
ability to have a decisive impact on
them if we compare the process by which
a human mind makes judgments to a
computer's process there's the input of
external data calculation and then the
final outcome what we're able to do is
omit the calculation step of the process
and directly produce an outcome when a
certain piece of information enters the
brain it exerts an influence on a
particular part of the neural network
and we can cause the brain to render a
judgment to believe that the information
is genuine without even thinking about
it has this already been achieved changa
asked softly yes it started with the
chance discovery which we subjected to
in-depth research and now we've done it
we call it the mental
seal to confirm this bill subjects
himself to the process with the
statement water is toxic and as a result
he begins to genuinely believe that
water is in fact toxic consequently he
undergos a two-month Psychotherapy
program to regain the ability to drink
water without hesitation if a person is
given a judgment that is at odds with
reality
it would be eventually overturned but
the process was painful because the
Judgment produced in the Mind by the
mental seal was extremely stubborn but
this was only with very clearly false
proclamations other judges would be
essentially impossible to overturn like
the existence of God or whether or not
Humanity might win a particular war
against a particular race of
aliens these don't have a clearly
determined answer and in the normal
course of a establishing these beliefs
the mind is slightly tilted in a certain
direction by all sorts of choices if the
belief is established by the mental seal
it will be Rock Solid and absolutely
unshakable to understand how the mental
seal relates to hines's plan you have to
understand the concept of the
triumphalist versus the defe they are
essentially opposite schools of thought
on how humans should deal with the
trican crisis the triumphalist believed
that Humanity could defeat the trican
through strength and determinism while
defe is to believe that we could not win
against the trican and ultimately
trended towards the idea of escapism
essentially they thought Humanity should
be preparing to run away from our solar
system and let the trican have Earth
escapism had of course been banned early
on by the governments of the world as it
had been universally decided that
Humanity would not flee but instead
would face the crisis headon on the
surface hines's plan was to use the
mental seal on people in order to make
them triumphalist this would instill the
belief in Humanity's survival and
theoretically give us a higher chance of
success in the war against tric
Solaris this obviously brings up all
sorts of moral dilemas surrounding free
will once Hines unveils it by this point
in time many have denounced the wall
facer project and some called for its
dissolution many viewed hines's mental
seal as a Herald of the of Humanity's
individuality and Free Will many believe
that the mental seal was the equivalent
of thought control look at you all
facers the Russian representative said
raising his hands towards the ceiling
Tyler wanted to deprive the people of
their lives and you want to deprive them
of their minds what are you trying to do
it was decided that no one would be
forced to use the mental seal it would
be completely voluntary it was proposed
that the mental seal be opened like a
public public facility it would have
only one proposition the belief in human
victory in the trican war anyone willing
to gain true Faith through use of the
mental seal could use the facility and
all of this would be conducted under the
strictest supervision and the person
would be given multiple chances to
change their minds before making the
final decision but there is a Twist here
it turns out that Hines himself was a
defeatist Hines had actually secretly
switched the code of the mental seal
device rather than make people
triumphalist they gained a belief in
absolute defeatism the mental seal was
an incredibly complicated piece of
equipment so although everything was
strictly supervised even the technical
details of the mental seal there were
still gaps in that
supervision when the neuros circuit
model for judging a proposition to be
true was discovered Hines also
discovered the model for judging a
proposition to be false that was what he
knew needed he concealed this discovery
from everyone including me it wasn't
difficult because the two models were
highly similar it manifested as the
direction of flow of a key signal in the
neuron transmission model and in the
mathematical model of the mental seal it
was represented by a sign positive for
true negative for false working in
extreme secrecy Hines manipulated the
sign in the mental seals Control
software in all five devices the sign
was negative
Hines had done this because he believed
that escapism was the only practical
means for survival for Humanity but by
the time this all comes to light Hines
is faced with a paradox before the
Doomsday battle would claimed countless
human souls and in in the destruction of
Humanity's entire space force victory
for Humanity had almost seemed certain
in the eyes of many Hines was still
under the influence of his mental seill
at this point and because of this he
nearly suffered a mental breakdown as a
result of the conflict of the mental
Seal's judgment and reality he can see
all that Humanity has done and how far
they've come and he understands that
victory in the war should belong to
humanity and yet due to the mental seal
he cannot believe it yes dear if you
permit me to call you that only by doing
that could I obtain the spiritual
strength necessary to execute the plan
yes right now I believe all I have done
is correct I absolutely believe it
regardless of what reality says I use
the mental seal to turn myself into my
own God and God can't repent he remarks
after the Doomsday battle that he might
have been the only person who actually
benefited from the destruction of
Humanity's space force the eventual
revelation of the truth of what hines's
mental seal did led to anxiety amongst
the citizens of Earth by this time it
had been nearly two centuries since the
mental seal was first used still because
of the availability of cryic Technology
anyone perhaps even those within the
government or military could be secret
defeatist intent on sabotaging
Humanity's chance of victory in favor of
escapism it's just speculation that the
imprinted have endured it's been over
170 years after all if a class or
organization would such an absolute
faith in defeating ISM exist why haven't
there been any signs of it there are two
possibilities the representative of the
European Fleet said one is that the
mental seal vanished long ago and this
is just a false alarm the representative
of the Asian Fleet completed his thought
but there's another
possibility the most frightening thing
about the situation is the fact that
there aren't any
signs the second possibility was
terrifying because it would suggest that
those imprinted with the mental seal in
fact survived but remain hidden amongst
them a person who developed a defe
mentality naturally would speak to
others of their thoughts but a person
with a 100% unshakable belief in
defeatism created by the mental seal
would inevitably develop a corresponding
sense of mission a religious-like
fanaticism based on the first belief
that Humanity will lose the trican war
defeatism and escapism are intimately
related and if the imprinted really
exist then their ultimate mission is
bound to be accomplishing an escape into
the universe but to achieve this goal
they have to deeply conceal their true
thoughts in the end hindes has proven
correct escapism would indeed be the
only hope for Humanity as a listener in
the dark would eventually notice our
solar system and casually fling a solar
system destroying weapon in our
Direction we've covered these events
already in this
video part four Manuel re Diaz's
plan wallfacer Manuel Ray Diaz the
former president of Venezuela emerges as
a central figure in the series with a
profound and alarming agenda as one of
the four wall facers he embarks on a
mission that seeks to secure Humanity's
survival in the face of an impending
threat from the triolian fleet but his
philosophy leans more in the direction
of if we can't keep our solar system you
can't have it either his strategy though
initially focusing on the development of
more powerful hydrogen bombs evolves
into a chilling scheme that could
potentially spell Doom for the entire
solar system Diaz's initial objective as
I said centers around the creation of
enhanced hydrogen bombs with the goal of
countering the imminent threat po osed
by the trican fleet to facilitate this
endeavor he Retreats into a state of
hibernation dedicating himself to
intensive research and development
however as the narrative unfolds it
becomes evident that his Ambitions have
taken an ominous turn in the crisis year
20 Diaz awakens to a dramatically
altered landscape Humanity has succeeded
in crafting a stellar hydrogen bomb
rendering his initial Quest obsolete
instead of conceding defeat Diaz devises
a new plan to construct a vast Cavern on
the planet Mercury where he intends to
detonate the Stellar hydrogen bombs this
Cavern aside from serving as the
launching site for these powerful
weapons also holds the purpose of
providing Earth with the last line of
defense should the trican fleet achieve
Victory the turning point in this
narrative occurs when Diaz's wall
breaker confronts him following the
catastrophic Mercury detonation event it
is then revealed that his plans are
nothing short of diabolical Diaz sought
to drain the oceans of vital resources
in order to create the ultimate
bomb evidently Wallace or re Diaz
doesn't just want to make a small sun he
wants to make a small Galaxy the US
representative said loudly then he
leaned towards Reay Diaz do you really
think that the oceans prodium Dum and
tridium were prepared just for you
because of your perverted affection for
the bomb the Earth should be turned into
a bomb Workshop Diaz's true intention is
to triggered the simultaneous explosion
of a thousand Stellar hydrogen bombs on
Mercury causing the planet to degrade in
its orbit and plunge into the Sun the
catastrophic Fallout of this Chain
Reaction would result in the sun
exploding unleashing devastating solar
flares that would ultimately draw the
inner planets of the solar system
including the Colossal Jupiter the
catastrophic outcome of this plan was
nothing short of an apocalyptic scenario
one that would obliterate all habitable
planets within the solar system and
extinguish all life on Earth in the
process essentially this was raz's
Twisted Insane idea of mutually assured
destruction but in a more direct and
crude sense than Lu G's plan which we
will talk about next the gravity of
das's actions do not escape the UN
planetary defense which reacts with
horror to the magnitude of the threat
that he poses to humanity itself they
considered charging him with the
extinction of life on Earth law
recognizing the gravity of his
intentions in a last ditch effort to
preserve his own safety Diaz revealed
that he has rigged a dead man switch
which would trigger the detonation of a
bomb in nearby New York unleashing
further chaos and destruction faced with
this perilous ultimatum the council is
forced to negotiate an exit plan for
Diaz as Diaz returns to his hometown in
Venezuela after years of seclusion the
residents are quick to react to the
horrifying Revelations about his plan
outraged by his intentions to annihilate
all life they they take justice into
their own hands and stone him to death
on sight radius held up his hands with
tears in his eyes and called out to the
crowd in a voice dripping with emotion
oh my people the first stone thrown by
his people struck him on his
outstretched left hand the second hit
him in the chest and the third smashed
into his forehead and nearly knocked him
out after that the people's Stones came
like raindrops and had practically
buried his lifeless body Body by the end
the last stone that hit wallface R Diaz
was thrown by an old woman who struggled
to carry it up to his corpse then said
in Spanish evildoer you would kill
everyone my grandson my grandson would
have been there you'd have killed my
grandson then using all the strength in
her trembling hands she slammed her
Stone against radius's Broken Skull
where it lay exposed beneath the pile of
rocks this conclusion highlights the
depths of fear and betrayal that Reay
Diaz's actions had sown Diaz was mad but
he was trying to help Humanity in his
own way and yet he is viewed by the
world including his own people as a
traitor to humanity this is because the
wall faers were given immense power but
not absolute unlimited power they had no
right to place Humanity in imminent
danger for this Reay Diaz like Frederick
Tyler was judged by history as one of
Humanity's biggest traitors though
Humanity's savior Lu G would use the
hydrogen bomb technology Diaz helped to
develop in his plan part five luo G's
plan now I've covered luig G's Plan
before on this channel in this video why
is space malicious but we will go over
it again here for clarity's sake luo G
was chosen to be a wall facer seemingly
at random it is eventually revealed that
the reason he was actually chosen was
not due to his skills or profession but
for one reason alone it was understood
that the trican wanted him dead the
reason for this related back to a chance
encounter he had had with one woman y
Wii the woman who was not only
instrumental in the creation of ETO but
was also the individual who initially
alerted the aliens to our presence and
the location of the earth ya Wii had
been the original traiter of
humanity ya Wii introduced Lui to a
concept known as Cosmic sociology Cosmic
sociology was based on two tenants one
there are a limited number of resources
in the universe two the goal of
civilization is to expand these tenants
seem simple but once you extrapolate
from the tenants a terrifying picture
emerges if the goal of civilization is
to expand and there are limited
resources in the universe this suggests
that expanding civilizations would be
forced to compete with each other for
those resources this is where the
concept of the Dark Forest comes from it
is mentioned that tricin considered the
Dark Forest state of the cosmos as The
Greatest Secret in the human universe
and because of what ya Wii had said to
him by chance years earlier luu G
figured it out the first test of Lu G's
Theory would take 50 years to complete
he would use prionic technology during
this time he called it a spell using the
sun's radio wave magnification
capabilities they would transmit the
message into space including three
simple images and some extra data to
show they were sent by an intelligent
Source all three images depicted planets
in the star system 187 j3 X1 the star
system 187 j3 X1 was approximately 50
light years away so obviously it would
take at least that amount of time to see
if his spell had any effect Lu
instructed them to wake him up from
hibernation only when the Spell's impact
was detected however his wishes were not
honored and he actually remained in
hibernation for approximately 200 years
by this time the wallfacer project had
faded Into Obscurity many in the current
ERA viewed the decision to create the
wallfacer project as a significant error
by the leaders of the past by this era
Lu G was regarded as an ordinary citizen
it wasn't until after the Doomsday
battle which decimated Earth space force
that the wallfacer project was
reinstated and Luigi's status was
restored the reason for this revival was
straightforward his spell had succeeded
they just didn't notice it into much
later lui's spell had exposed the
location of the star 187j 3x1 to the
wider Universe indicating that it
harbored life despite lui's knowledge to
the contrary of course because Luigi is
not a genocidal Maniac the outcome was
the same the star had remained stable
and had not naturally gone Supernova
then just before its destruction a tiny
object called a photo traveling at near
the speed of light was observed hurtling
towards the star the resulting explosion
obliterated all four planets in the star
system l g then fully comprehended why
he had been chosen as a wall facer the
trican saw his demise because they knew
he was close to uncovering the secret
they desperately wanted to hide from
Humanity the universe was actively
hostile and any intelligent life that
revealed itself was ultimately
eradicated by technologically Superior
civilization the universe was a dark
Forest at this point Earth's location
had only been disclosed to the tricar
the aliens knew that if Humanity
discovered the universe is secret they
might reveal the location of tric
Solaris dooming both
civilizations Lu G's plan from there on
was straightforward hold the tricin in a
state of ultimate deterrence by
threatening mutually assured destruction
repurposing Manuel radius's hydrogen
bomb Tech the success of Dark Forest
deterrence was founded on the
unpredictability of luo G as an
individual if deterrant failed his
actions would be guided by his own
personality and psychology even if he
acted rationally his own interest might
not match Humanity's interest perfectly
at the beginning of the deterrence era
both tricas and Earth carefully analyzed
luo G's personality and built up
detailed mathematical models both the
triance and Humanity judged luo G's
percentage of carrying out the threat
should the need arise to be between 92
and
98% as I've said I go into more detail
on how exactly Lu G accomplished this in
my deterrent era video so check that out
if you want all the details on that
conclusion one wallfacer betrays
Humanity in favor of the tricin another
attempts to alter the minds of people to
believe his ideology another puts the
entire solar system in Jeopardy in a
craze scheme and the last succeeds at
deterring the
tricin in conclusion the wall facers and
lisan Trilogy symbolize a profound
exploration of multifaceted themes each
as crucial as the last they present
aaric departure from Humanity's
Collective efforts en countering the
trican threat forcing us to ponder the
role of individuals in shaping history
and the potential for individual agency
when confronted with global changes
however their actions also pose ethical
and moral dilemas as they sometimes
resort to morally ambiguous or
controversial strategies in Earth's
defense prompting the reader to consider
the repr percussions of making ethically
challenging decisions under the looming
Spectre of annihilation the wallfacer
extraordinary power and autonomy kind of
invite us to scrutinize the very nature
of power itself its consolidation in the
hands of a select few and The Perils of
unchecked
authority this concept also serves as a
lens through which we can examine the
intricacies of global politics diplomacy
and international collaboration which is
a major theme of this series
in times of impending doom it also calls
to attention how governments and also
individuals react to existential threats
and how this underscores the roles of
political leaders and institutions
shaping our future at many times in
human history the course of all of
history the fate of all mankind rests
within the hands of just a few
people that is the point behind the wall
facer project that is the idea that
Lucian is attempting to explore
ultimately the wall facer concept adds
depth and complexity to the narrative
and helps to explore even more the ideas
revolving around communication power and
ethics and the human response to an
alien
menace thanks guys so much for watching
make sure you like And subscribe for
more Quinn's ideas for more videos on
this particular book series check out
the three body problem playlist in the
description thanks
guys as I said you can check out our
patreon if you would like to support
this Channel or use the PayPal Link in
the description thanks
[Music]
guys
oh